[Musique]
ce sont les visages de la relève en
soins infirmiers après deux petites
semaines l'université ces jeunes sont
loin d'être découragés par la crise
la relève on est là pour changer le
visage la pandémie ne les a pas éloigné
du secteur de la santé au contraire chez
plusieurs saint-même éveillé une
vocation c'est le cas de gabriel inspiré
par sa tâche de proposer en ch et celle
des pendant la pandémie je voyais la job
d intérieur tellement impressionné par
sa fille tellement une belle équipe où
c'est qu'on avait autour de lui que moi
je me suis dit je l'attends
malik tu vas être 9,1 à quitter le
secteur bancaire je le fais vraiment
parce que j'ai besoin d'être utile au
quotidien et et peut-être que j'accepte
de moins bien gagner ma vie en faisant
infirmiers l'on me levant avec le
sourire au visage le matin quand je vais
aller travailler les demandes
d'admission en baisse depuis 2000 17 ont
remonté de manière importante cette
année en augmentation de 10% de nous
demande d'admission au baccalauréat la
formation initiale l'université de
sherbrooke note une hausse de 15% le
nombre de demandes d'admission s'est
stabilisé à mes guile et à l'université
laval
tout comme pour les cours de technique
en soins infirmiers dans les cégeps
les aspirantes infirmières comprennent
le problème de surcharge de travail mais
voilà crise actuelle comme une occasion
de régler le problème la crise qu'on
vient ce moment c'est une chance pour le
gouvernement d améliorer puis prendre
exemple sur d'autres pays puis vraiment
aller chercher créer quelque chose un
système nouveau qui va être encore mieux
ici david gêne-t-il et radio canada
montréal